je vous annonce que j'ai pris la
décision de me porter candidate à la
direction du parti québécois nous allons
être pas un bon gouvernement n'ose ty
bamboo on se rend compte que le caucus
et déconnecter les dépendances
le quesnoy reprendre à zéro je vais
participer à tous les débats que le
parti québécois organisme désolé mais
avez vous déjà eu cette force et des
gens à avoir du fun dans un portique
c'est impossible
l'identité ne se force poppy ça c'est
comme si vous disiez la paix on est
parti vers l'eau mais inquiétez-vous
beau dans le premier moment de l'eau on
voit bien ce qui m'agace profondément
martin sait que c'est un ministre c'est
toi donc ce que je dis et je me suis dit
dans la balance des inconvénients non
pose une question et doute la réponse de
ce nous propose c'est un traumatisme
dans le parti québécois
six mois avant l'élection de 2018 sera
d'abord payer un super jean-françois
là on sent tendu pour un ou deux
bouteilles de répliquer je n'embarque
plus là dedans je veux plus répondre à
ces questions là cet homme est
détestable il est trop présent dans
notre débat je vais parler d'autres je
suis obligé d'admettre qu'un sans bouger
sur le g20 n'a pas bougé dans les
dernières semaines et que de toute
évidence la course s'est resserrée et en
alberta passe très souvent c'est
unilingue anglais pourquoi pour québec
ça pourrait pas être en français mais un
cadre légal à respecter martin puis
c'est malheureux mais on doit le
respecter
makan a raté
eiffage est dédié à jean françois l'eau
j'écoute désir stéphane dion sort de cet
ordre soit tu veux changer la loi 101
pour enlever suspects que camille
laurens et rené lévesque il y avait mis
soit tu arrêtes de match aller avec ça
ah bon